hello and welcome everyone to yet
another
exciting live session from simply learn
today we will discuss the differences
between c
c plus plus and java programming
languages
let us wait for an ample amount of time
so that few more people can tune in
by the time please allow me to tell you
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies
if you are the tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then please consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from our end
welcome guys so now let's begin
so we are here to discuss the
differences between the legendary
programming language that is the c
programming language
versus the well esteemed object oriented
version of the c programming language
that is the c plus plus programming
language versus the
unrivaled monarch of the current iit
industry that is the java
so without further delay let's dive into
our topic for today's discussion
so the first point on discussion about
the differences between the three
languages
is the object oriented programming
nature
at first we have the c programming
language which is the procedural
programming language
it does not have any kind of object
oriented programming features in it
whereas on the other hand we have the c
plus programming language which is a
little advanced version of c programming
language
and it comes with the object oriented
programming feature
followed by c plus plus we have the java
programming language
which is right from its birth is an
object oriented programming language
and it also supports cross platforms
followed by the object-oriented
programming nature we have the second
point of discussion about the
differences of three languages
that is the platform dependency
so first we have c programming language
which is completely
platform dependent for example let us
consider that we have written a
program in windows operating system and
wanted to run the same program
in a different computer system which is
running on linux or some other kind of
operating system
so unless you make some tweaks to your
code you cannot
run that and similarly we have c
plus programming language which also has
the same properties
which is not platform independent
similar to c programming language even c
plus plus is
platform dependent and finally we have
java which has been so famous just
because of its platform
independent nature it is because of its
jvm or java virtual machine which makes
it possible to run the programs
in any operating system regardless of
the version
of flavor so followed by the platform
dependent nature
we have the next point of discussion
amongst the differences between the
three programming languages
that is the enterprise support offered
now enterprise support is
a little bit different from the regular
standard
individual support nature for example
you are a sole developer and you are
developing an application or program for
your
sole purposes so unlike the individual
purpose
enterprise support is something like an
organizational goal where multiple
programmers or a team of programmers
work on single goal so
when it comes to enterprise support c
programming does not have enterprise
support
and when it comes to c plus plus
programming language
there is enterprise support but not to a
greater extent
it can support limited enterprise
requirements
and finally we have java which has a
fully fledged enterprise support
now the next point of discussion after
the enterprise support is the
compiler operational procedures
now coming into the c programming
language we have one single compiler in
c
programming language and whatever the
program you write
will be considered for compilation stage
after the program is finished
so the entire program is considered
for compilation process at once and this
reduces time for compilation
so coming into c plus programming
language it follows the same procedures
of c
programming language status the entire
program is considered for compilation
stage
after the program is finished so
at the stages of compilation both the
programming languages c
and c plus are really fast
so now let's get into the java
programming language so java has
a mild hybrid kind of compiler which is
a combination of both
compiler and an interpreter so whatever
the code you write in java programming
language
the interpreter tries to interpret your
code and sometimes even provide you
suggestions when you're using some
high-end
ideas like eclipse and finally at the
end
the complete code is compiled again
before providing the
runtime output so this type of
interpretation and compilation
makes java a little bit slower but not
completely slower now followed by the
compiler execution
processes we have the next point of
discussion which is
the file extensions
so the c follows dot c file extensions
and similarly
c plus plus follows c p p file
extensions
and finally java follows dot java
extensions
so when you have a file with dot c you
can directly recognize it as
the c programming language and cpp for c
plus plus and finally java for java
files
now we have our sixth point of
discussion about the differences between
the three programming languages
that is the data types and keywords
so the common point between all the
three languages is they have
two data types which are the primitive
and non-primitive data types
whereas the number of keywords the
programming languages use
are a little different so coming into c
programming language we have two types
of data types which are primitive and
non-primitive data types and coming into
keywords
c programming language follows 32
keywords
for use so keywords are those special
words which have special meanings
and the meanings to those words are
predefined by the designers or
the creators of c programming language
followed by c we have c plus plus and
same as
c programming language c plus plus also
has
two different types of data types which
are primitive and non-primitive and
finally they have
63 different keywords for use
which are nearly double the previous
existing programming language which is
the c programming language
so now coming into java programming
language we have two different types of
data types which are
primitive and non-primitive and finally
they have
50 different keywords for use
so followed by this we have our next
point of discussion which is
the seventh point of discussion amongst
the differences between the three
programming languages
that is the database connectivity now
database connectivity plays a
major role based on the current trends
of programming
now let's see what's the differences had
to say about it
so first we have the c programming
language which has no
support for database connectivity and
similarly
there is no special or any type of
database connectivity support
even in c plus programming language
so now coming into java programming
language we have a huge
and strong support for database
connectivity
java has special connectors like jdbc
which is
the java database connector now after
database connectivity we have the next
point of difference which is the
exception handling support
by the programming languages at first we
have the c
programming language which has zero
support for exception handling
now exception handling is a simple
procedure
which eliminates the process of a code
segment
in a complete program to fail or
sometimes it does not even
allow the complete program to fail just
because of some
mild programming errors now to
understand exception handling in a much
better way i'll drop down a link in the
description box below
which will explain you about the
exception handling in a much better way
so followed by c programming language we
have the c plus
programming language which also barely
shows support for exception handling
now and finally we have java programming
language which has
strong support for exception handling
now followed by exception handling the
next point of discussion
is the structures and unions
so the structures and unions were first
introduced nc programming language
so c has the better support for them and
followed by that even
in c plus plus programming language we
have a good support for structures and
unions
so structures and unions act as special
type of
a data structure which is capable enough
to store
multiple data which is belonging to
different
kinds of data types for example if you
consider the structure or a union
of a student then it has various types
of data types for example
the student name is character data type
role number can be integer
and has percentage in the annual or
academic year
could be float so we have different
types of data types
considered into one single unit as a
structure
or a union so when we come into java
it does not have the support for
customized data structures like
structures and unions now the next point
of discussion is
the data security
now c being the procedural programming
language it does not support the object
oriented nature
which is the encapsulation so however
you try
there is always a lack of security for
your data in c programming language
when you come into c plus programming
language we do have the support for
encapsulation so there can be a limited
security available
at c plus programming language now
whereas on the other hand
java being the most advanced level
object oriented programming language
which has special features for data
security supports
100 security for your data now
next point of discussion we have on our
docket is
the multi-threading now compared to
other programming languages
c programming language is a much older
and
procedural oriented programming language
so it has
low support or even no support for
multi-threading
so followed by c programming language we
have the c plus
programming language so even the c plus
plus programming language
has no support for multi-threading it's
just an advanced version of c
but not totally advanced so when we come
into java programming language
it is the far more advanced programming
language till today
so it has a greater support for
multi-threading
this eventually improvises the
performance capabilities of the
programming language
so followed by multi-threading the next
point of discussion we have is the
support for constructors
and destructors so at first we have the
c
programming language so c programming
language is not an object-oriented
programming language
so it does not have the support for
constructors and destructors
so when we come into c plus plus
programming language
it is an advanced version of c
programming language which has
object oriented programming features and
the support for constructors
and destructors now coming into java
programming language
even java programming language is an
object oriented programming language
and has the support of constructors but
does not have the support for
destructors so destructors are basically
replaced by garbage collector which
automatically clears
the memory or unused memory after the
complete execution of program
so the next point of discussion that we
have in our docket is
the garbage collector so c
programming language being the
procedural programming language did not
find any requirement of destructors or
the garbage collector so coming into c
plus plus programming language
it always had a destructor so user was
supposed to manually write in a
destructor code
and release the unused memory after the
execution of program
so it did not literally have a garbage
collector but something
which posed similarity of a garbage
collector
and finally when we come into java
programming language it has the
completely
developed and functional garbage
collector
so followed by that the next point of
discussion we have is
the pointers so c
programming language had a support for
pointers
followed by that the c programming
language also had the support for
pointers
so finally coming into java so java did
not find the requirement of
pointers so they were not defined in the
programming language
so we cannot find pointers being used in
java programming language
followed by that we have the
preprocessor directives as a
15th point of discussion which is going
to be a last point of discussion
about the differences between the three
programming
languages so first we have the c
programming language which has the
preprocessor directives
so to include the preprocessor
directives we need to have
the hash include statement before
writing the program
so similarly in c plus programming
language we need to write in
the hash include command before using
the preprocessor directives into the
program
so when we come into java programming
language we have a little difference
we use the import command to access the
libraries
so with that we come to an end of this
discussion
so with all the differences discussed i
lead the decision of declaring the
winner to you
now if you have any queries related to
java or any of these programming
languages
or if you feel we missed out something
crucial
then please feel free to drop them all
in the comment section below
and we will be happy to consider and
respond to every single comment you
leave for us
so this is rafi signing off and until
next time
thank you
you